ich lese ja mit meiner ich bin ein
riesen fan von dieser brille
wieso weil du aussiehst wie die lehrerin
in einem porno
wie gehst du vor du bekommst jetzt die
liste von büchern die duh besprechen
musst und dann also zunächst mal weiß
ich jetzt sehr zu schätzen wenn ich
tatsächlich die bücher lesen kann mit
denen ich bin darauf angewiesen dass ich
ganz viel in die bücher schreiben kann
manchmal wenn die bücher etwas
komplizierter sind dann mache ich mir
notizen zum ablauf hört damit auf nicola
das machen nur leute die kein leben
haben so was das ist der stammbaum des
buches das ist borderline ehre
ich stelle mir vor wie du unter einem
fensterlosen zimmer sitzt und diese
pläne schreibt mit einem bleistift und
wieder und wieder die bücher liegen
mir fällt nichts mehr dazu ein ich bin
großartig ist wirklich großartig ich
sollte nicht immer so schlecht über dich
reden
ich lese und dann schreibe ich dann eben
dann schreibe ich dann eben irgendwie
unfug ja unfug schreibe ich auch gerne
stellen die ich gut finde mag ich mit
einem kleinen g da mache ich einen kloß
ich habe manchmal kitschverdacht für
kitsch habe ich ein k
dann musste das ja alles noch auswerten
ich sitze dann so an meinem schreibtisch
und zähle meine cast so und dann ganz
zum schluss kommt alles hier im ein rot
rotes buch es funktioniert so dass sich
die notizen erst ausdrucke und dann
zurecht schneiden in dieses rote buch
hans fehr ihre und dann die besonders
wichtigen sache nochmal markieren und
das schreibst du ganze texte rheinnähe
findest du dass es sowas gibt wie
professionelles lesen und freizeit lesen
mich ja du musst doch bücher so lesen
wie du sie immer liest nicht oder nicht
mehr normal und ich lese ich lese ich
mir noch mal ein erschütterndes
bekenntnis wenn ich jetzt lese achte ich
auf die figuren ich achte auf motive ich
überlege wie ist der stil im sinne von
ähnlich wie bei und so weiter ist das
bedenklich weil wir ja eigentlich auch
über literatur sprechen sollen für
menschen die das nicht professionell
linie sind das finde ich auch wichtig
ich finde schon wichtig die überlegungen
kann man dieses jahr jemandem zur
lektüre empfehlen
jetzt nicht so wie wir ständig alles
liest geht es dir auch so dass du
ungefähr gleich viel positive wie
negative anmerkungen machst oder hast du
die anmerkung mehr reserviert für gute
stellen häufiger gute und ab und zu
schlecht besonders gut gefallen mir
glaube ich auch schneller auf als
besonders schlecht die wahrscheinlich
nicht
[Gelächter]